Charlie is just an average teenage boy
but when he hears the cry for help help
me I'm bored
Charlie becomes YouTube boy
unfortunately YouTube boy
only has one superpower he can make
pretty good YouTube videos off you go
Charlie
make a video go on Charlie yes so
Charlie yes so Charlie is so cool
hello I've had lots of stuff going on as
you probably already guessed from the
fact that I was on TV which completely
freaked me out if you look at the
beginning when I first appear for a
second I'm just completely gormless and
then I come back to life they said they
were gonna meet me later and then they
just started filming me but that is not
the point of this video no Lulu
as you have probably already guessed
from the title this video is gonna be a
competition
yay and not only is it a competition but
it's a competition with prizes yeah
before I tell you what the prizes are
I'm gonna tell you how you can answer
basically I want you guys to make a
video response to this video doing your
best impression of me I'm sure you guys
are creative enough to come up with
something amazingly funny
I'll stop accepting entries in one
week's time one week from when I posted
this video ok you don't have to be
subscribed to me don't worry about that
so I'm gonna tell you what the prizes
are now the runner-up will get this
which is a little Pac Man Thing I don't
really know what it is but it's quite
cool it's not very good the best way
it's the runner-up prize but if you win
I mean somebody's gonna win and then you
will get this and this now this is the
mug that I used in my how to make a cup
of tea video a mug and the mug that I
used in my take my mug video pick up a
mug take it drink it finally somebody is
gonna get a chance to take my mug
it's not great smoke in the world but
it's ergonomically designed
ergonomically designed so you win that
and you'll also win this this is an
official YouTube t-shirt you can't buy
this just to prove it is an official
t-shirt you can see the YouTube logo in
there and it's pretty damn awesome to be
perfectly honest with you you're on it
you're on it I just realized that all of
the prizes of loom
yeah that was worth Mele so yeah make a
video response do your best impression
of me and make fun of me as much as
possible yeah you guys have got good
ideas your creative come up with
something amazing okay yeah right I've
got to go have so I'll see you guys
later